anger and disappointment for thousands
of residents confined to their homes on
the kuacheng estate one of hong kong's
largest public housing complexes a
five-day lockdown was supposed to end
wednesday until more infections were
detected to place safe protecting the
residents as well as preventing the
spread of this virus
we have no choice but to extend
the restricted testing declaration for
another two days
those in lockdown say the government
orders have been confusing
the government announced the arrangement
very late we have no idea when to go for
the mandatory tests
i think the government's plan is without
due diligence it is inconvenient for
elderly like me we are not familiar with
smartphones
people living here say that the daily
cues for testing make them anxious
because the area is overcrowded and
waiting times can be too long
poor hygiene conditions and piles of
rubbish are also a concern visa and his
heart very bad
there is garbage in the staircases every
day the government's arrangement is very
bad too as you can see from this cue
it is much easier to get covered
and many worry that the strict lockdown
will be extended beyond friday and into
the chinese lunar new year holiday which
begins next week the restrictions are
part of hong kong's goal of stamping out
all covered transmission
yeah i think the reason why we are
adopting a dynamic zero policy is to uh
minimize the stress on the healthcare
system uh even the omen crime we know
that is a very mild disease and then of
course currently there are relatively
few cases in hospital and i think none
in the icu right now
the strict lock down here at kuichung
estate is an unprecedented move by the
hong kong government it's similar to the
strategies seen across the border in
mainland china which also takes a no
tolerance approach to the virus
concern too in china's capital the
winter olympics are due to start next
week in beijing
mass testing for two million residents
is underway in the southern fungthai
district of beijing as infections there
increase
china hopes mass testing and aggressive
quarantine rules will contain the virus
but as it prepares to ring in the year
of the tiger ongoing restrictions are
proving that omicron is tough to tame
brit clinic al jazeera hong kong